LEIGHA JARETT: Over the past few
"BigQuery Spotlight" episodes,
we've walked you through
the fundamentals of BigQuery
to help you get started
architecting and administering
your warehouse.
Today, we're going
beyond that initial setup
and talking about how you
can ensure that your BigQuery
environment stays cost
effective, performant,
and secure through
ongoing monitoring.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Monitoring your data warehouse
on a continuous basis
is important for
every organization.
Let's walk through
a few key use cases
so that you can understand
the different data sources
available to monitor and
the types of questions you
might be asking for each one.
First up, cost optimization.
One of the ways you can
monitor BigQuery spend
and Google Cloud
spend in general
is to leverage the
billing reports.
You can analyze billing data
directly in the Google Cloud
Console or export it
back into BigQuery
to join it against
other data sets
and create your
own custom reports.
Let's jump into the Cloud
Console to take a look.
In the Reports tab
of the Billing page,
we can see a chart with our
cost per a particular billing
account broken down by project,
service, SKU, or even label
keys.
Focusing on BigQuery
services, there
are a few different
actions you might
want to take using this data.
First off, you can
see how much money
is being spent on BigQuery
across different teams
or projects and use this to set
up budgets and notifications so
that you or others on your team
know if spend is getting out
of hand.
Or you can even set up
custom quotas for BigQuery
so that specific
users or projects
are limited in the amount
of data they can process.
Next, you might want to
dig into the storage SKUs
to look at a breakdown of
active versus long-term storage.
In case you don't already know,
BigQuery charges half the price
for data that has not
been modified in 90 days.
This includes entire tables
or specific partitions
within a table.
So this information
may be able to help
you modify the way you
update data or narrow down
tables that could be
partitioned to take advantage
of long-term storage.
Another SKU you may
see in the billing data
is for streaming inserts.
While BigQuery charges
for streaming inserts,
batch loading is free.
So if data being
streamed into BigQuery
doesn't need to be
consumed right away,
you might consider editing
your loading process.
Finally, the billing
reports can be
super helpful for
pinpointing projects that
have spikes in analysis cost.
Here, analysis means
on-demand querying,
where you're charged for
the amount of bytes scanned.
There might be an opportunity
to apply a slot reservation
to these projects to save costs
and ensure predictable pricing.
If you're not familiar
with BigQuery reservation
or BigQuery pricing
model, I highly
recommend that you go and visit
our "Jobs and Reservations"
video linked below.
Now, if you do decide to
go with flat-rate pricing,
you'll need to figure out
what reservation size makes
the most sense for your needs.
This brings us to
our second use case--
workload management and
performance monitoring.
You can see how many
slots were consumed
across different workloads
in your organization
using the Cloud Monitoring
interface or the information
schema tables natively
available in BigQuery.
For example, if your
historical slot consumptions
looks like this, you may
want to find the baseline
and purchase a
monthly or annual slot
commitment for that amount, in
this case, around 500 slots.
For queries that are
causing those peaks,
you could choose to purchase
a flex-slot commitment,
run the query, and then
cancel the commitment.
And as a reminder, the
number of available slots
is kind of like a
measure of throughput.
This means that if less
slots are available,
the query will likely
just run slower.
You can always test
out query performance
with different number of
slots to find the size that
works best for your needs.
Besides just determining the
size of your reservation,
you may also want to use Cloud
Monitoring or the information
schema to monitor
job performance.
And actually, if you're using
slot reservations already,
you can also use the new
BigQuery Admin Resource Charts.
Let's take a look.
This data can help
you pinpoint queries
that should be optimized,
like this scheduled query that
seems to be consuming
a lot of resources.
With the job ID, you can even
get the execution details
and use some of the
optimization techniques
we covered in our previous
video to figure out
if you can rewrite the
SQL to be more efficient.
You might also want to
dig into job concurrency
to rearrange scheduling for
optimal slot utilization
or fail jobs to
help troubleshoot
any ongoing issues.
OK, great.
So we've reviewed some ways
to save money and optimize
performance.
Now let's talk about how you can
audit data sharing and access
using Cloud Logging, which
allows you to analyze system
and application log data.
And just like our
other data sources,
logs can be analyzed
in the console
or exported into BigQuery.
In one of our
previous videos, we
talked about data governance.
You might remember that we use
data catalog to develop policy
tags for controlling access.
In Cloud Logging,
we can do things
like find the email address
for the principle that
grants or removes
access on a policy tag
or the email address for
whom the access was granted
or removed.
You can also directly see what
user identities have queried
which data sources, to ensure
that all access policies are
correct and no one has access
to data that they shouldn't.
As you can see, monitoring
is essential to making
informed decisions on optimizing
your BigQuery data warehouse.
As a quick review, you
can use the billing data
to create budgets,
custom quotas,
and dig into areas where
you can reduce costs
To size reservations, improve
performance, and troubleshoot
errors, you can use Cloud
Monitoring or the information
schema, or if
you're a reservation
customer, the new BigQuery
Admin Resource Charts.
Finally, you can
use Cloud Logging
to review granular
log data, which
also might be useful
for troubleshooting
and to monitor data
access policies.
The great part of
monitoring in BigQuery
is that you have the flexibility
to export any of these data
sources back into your data
warehouse for custom reporting.
In fact, we've even built
a series of Data Studio
and Looker templates
to accelerate
any additional
analysis you want to do
on top of billing, information
schema, or log data.
Make sure to check out the
links below for details,
and follow me on social to get
more BigQuery tips and tricks
Oh, and remember, stay curious.
[MUSIC PLAYING]